right well those are big problems
especially the loss of unsupervised play
it's not it's not obvious at all how
that might be addressed yes it is okay
good good everyone should buy everyone
should just buy Lenore scan Daisy's book
rearrange kids and then they should
loosen up and give their kids more
unsupervised time now you can't do this
alone you'll be arrested yeah I tried to
get my son to go out across the street
to you know buy groceries when he was
you know nine years old yeah and he'd
say like but you know daddy people look
at me funny there are no their kids out
there and so Lenore has started a
fantastic organization called
let grow so if you was go to let grow
dot org okay we'll put all this in the
description all of these things right so
I'm on the board of it as an advisor
Peter gray an expert on play is on the
board and they're doing these simple
things simple simple things like you
convince a school to just open up the
playground an hour early or keep it open
after school why should kids always have
organized activities and soccer practice
just give them a place to play where
there's a nurse available if someone
gets hurt there is an adult but he's not
supervising he's just over there right
so don't worry parents there is an adult
but beyond that do what they and they
just started this a few weeks ago and
the results are fantastic the kids are
having so much fun they are becoming
more independent they're more willing to
do projects on their own it's working
out great so that's really can't do this
on your own but the thing is so those
are very practical that's a very
practical piece of advice for schools
it's like open up the unsupervised play
facilities and and and facilitate their
use that's right
give give everyone a place which is safe
and by safe I mean physically safe right
never use the word safety to describe
emotions and ideas safety means physical
safety so you've got to provide a
physically safe place for the kids to
play and beyond that you let them go now
there will arise problems of bullying so
if it's repeated harassment oh you know
well I know a book about that which it's
by Dan always called bullying what we
know and what we can do about it and it
was written it's got to be 30 years ago
and always cut the rope
the the the the incidence of bullying in
the Scandinavian countries down by 50%
and he really really targets what
bullying means so he's not a safe space
guy by any stretch of the imagination I
don't know what the origins of it are I
know that the valuations of his program
in America show anywhere from zero to 20
percent reductions yeah well I small ER
in the u.s. in the u.s. yeah the
question is whether or not they were
able to implement them with rigor he did
in the US and yeah but bullying programs
are part of the problem because bullying
clearly is a problem we need to do
something about it but because we have
what's called concept creep yeah so so
it's not magic concept creep looks like
even yeah that's right so now it's the
case that if if kids don't invite if
some kids want to do something and they
don't invite another kid
they've excluded that kid right well
that could be bullying right I've read
of schools in Europe that don't allow
kids to have best friends for exactly
that reason
yeah well because the this is also
something that really bothers me about
the misuse of the IAT because it's not
that easy to distinguish in group
preference which no one can know one
when their right mind would want to
eliminate in group preference given that
it governs your choice of mate and your
behavior towards your family members
let's say to distinguish that between
out group exclusion is no in no simple
matter and to tell kids that they can't
have a best friend is another thing that
interferes with an important part of
their that's right yeah I think both of
us have spent a lot of time looking at
ancient wisdom at the writings of people
long ago and I often come back to
Aristotle's claim that any virtue
carried to extremes becomes a vice so
inclusion is a good thing if people are
being excluded because they have a
physical stigma or because or they're
overweight or their skin color so you
know we need to be looking at the
reasons why kids are excluded but if you
say inclusion is the primary virtue
inclusion over everything else and so if
those two best friends are excluding
others
no more best friend all right this is
madness yeah this is a vice so I think
that inclusion again you know it's a
virtue unless
to extremes